I was inspired to get involved in the
space program when the Apollo 11 lunar
landing happened on my seventh birthday
Capcom we're go for landing I'll do
there were echoes of that with the
landing of curiosity and 2012 planning
rebound so I never had the what you want
to be when you grow up or uncertainty
about what I want to be I always wanted
to work in the space program
[Music]
I think the overall goal of JPL is to
unlock the mysteries of the universe for
planet Earth and it's a privilege
exploring the cosmos on behalf of our
tiny they're brought from the Sun so T
makes us our advanced design team and
before anything becomes a project it's
really an idea and we help try to find
the solutions to a point designed to go
anywhere in our universe it's really
about turning an idea into a realizable
concept while one person might have an
idea in order to make that idea of
become a mission it takes a lot of
people to do that so it's really about
putting all the right people in the room
that can find that solution so if I had
a theory behind teamwork at JPL I would
split it up into two different arenas
scientists working with scientists is
one kind of team work on curiosity the
science community there's several
aspects of their approach to how they
make decision making of course we have
the overall objectives of the mission is
to assess the habitability and
habitability history of Mars there is a
project science group which are the most
senior scientist led by our principal
investigator for the mission and they
are the ones who set the overarching
strategic goals for the science
community then there's the other arena
which is the the work of doing a mission
so the Cassini mission is a flagship
mission to Saturn we're about to embark
on an incredible in division there were
big questions that we did not have
answered big questions about Saturn's
interior big questions about the mass of
the B ring and one of the ways to answer
those questions was to plunge the
spacecraft in between the planet and the
Rings and so the scientists went to the
experts the navigation team that does
the trajectory and they said so what do
you all think is this possible and they
worked for many years and we work
together and we came up with this
exciting end of mission
that is going to take us 22 times in
between the planet and the Rings until
finally we plunge into the planet itself
it all starts with the scientists but
you very quickly have to pull in the
rest of the team as with many projects
there's this healthy tug-of-war between
science and engineering we always want
to do our best for the scientists but
sometimes we have to protect them from
their own voracious appetites they want
to do so much and we encourage that but
not at the expense of our spacecraft the
engineers need to understand what the
science is going after so that they can
help us and the scientists need to
understand what the engineers are
worried about and what is causing them
to have constraints on what the science
is that we do even when we have an
engineering meeting we make sure science
is well represented so that they can
tell any little thing we're doing this
spacecraft that might affect science
return and then similarly when
scientists are meeting there's often
engineering representatives to have this
dose of reality make sure that anything
they're trying to do is say for the
spacecraft we then also have a set of
strategic and super tactical teams who
are thinking ahead what should be our
our goals and where should we be
steering the vehicle so you maximize the
science and yet or as safe as possible
risk averse with engineering
it's really exciting to see a team come
together in that collective knowledge
solving a problem when there's no one
person that could pull that off if we
bring the team together that fosters a
spirit of camaraderie we appreciate each
other more and our unique challenges and
what it takes to make the vehicle work
it isn't about the personality it's
about what are we going to learn for the
benefit of humanity
I think the future of space exploration
is very bright we're going to extend
human presence in the solar system
there's a whole universe out there
waiting to export you can't wait to do
it
[Music]